[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout
if you're joining for the first time
it's great to meet you i'm rachel i'm
the host of the hangout if this is your
first hangout what is it this is an open
space for the whole data science
community
to connect and chat
about some of the more human-centric
questions around data science leadership
questions you're facing
and what's going on in the world of data
science
so we want this to be a space where
everybody can participate
and you can ask questions three
different kinds of ways so you can jump
in live and just raise your hand on zoom
and i can call on you you could put
questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to your question if you want me to
read it out maybe you're in a coffee
shop or your dog's barking or something
but we also have a slido link where you
can ask questions anonymously too
and tyler will put that and oh she
already did it she put that in the chat
right now
just like to reiterate though that we
love to hear from everybody no matter
your level of experience or your area of
work
you will notice that we had a little bit
of a last-minute change of plans today
and i'm so excited to be joined by
michael chao who is stepping in as our
featured leader today so michael is a
software engineer at our studio
and previously led the data science team
at california integrated travel project
and michael i'd love to just turn it
over to you and have you kind of
introduce yourself and share a bit about
the work you do
sure yeah thanks for having me um so i
did a phd in a different life
phd in cognitive psychology
and then i sort of flew the coop to
industry where i worked on um
educational tools and tools to measure
data science skill
um
and then uh
yep switched to
uh working on building out a data
science team
at california integrated travel project
um i'm really interested in sort of
but i i will say i love the tidy verse
i'm really interested in sort of like
how people can do analytics fast and
what makes like really skillful
data scientists and data science teams
um so i'm really excited to be here and
now i'm working at our studio as an
engineer and then as a kind of weird
side thing um
for the past years i co-directed an org
called code for philly
um which just tries to connect
volunteers to
non-profits in philadelphia
um to throw like experts or like a
hundred volunteers at really impactful
projects in the city so happy to be here
really excited to
you know
connect with people in data science and
you know discuss kind of
all the weird
parts of of data science and data
science teams
awesome thanks michael while we're
waiting for people to jump in with their
own questions i'd love to kick it off by
asking you
what's something that you're most
excited about
in regards to data science and thinking
about the year ahead
yeah i i feel like um
they're kind of like two
two things um
one is uh and this this has really been
growing over time but i think tools like
dbt
and um
the tools of like the modern data stack
to really build out
a very
nice warehouse quickly um
are just absolutely killer i think that
the the amount of ground a person can
cover
once they've kind of like wrangled these
tools is so
great
um i'd say on the other hand
i still like for the past decade have
felt so excited about tools like d plier
in r
and the tidy verse
and and on the other side like its
ability to let people query data
freakishly fast so i feel like dbt is
kind of the new thing i'm excited about
the pliers the thing i've been like
excited about for the last decade
somehow and it's just stayed on like
the top of my
list
awesome so i've been hearing about dbt a
bit more but i will admit i don't really
know exactly what it means could you
explain it a bit more
yeah i i would say so like um something
i've seen before is um
uh like imagine you're a person
building out like so you've got all this
data into a warehouse it's just loaded
up it like needs to be cleaned and made
into like a data mart so people can
like end users can consume it
you're a person in charge of that like
uh there was a point in time where it
wasn't crazy that that might just be a
folder of sql scripts and then a
weird some weird custom script to
somehow like chain them all together
and
uh it just absolute chaos
so dbt
uh they're really focused on analytics
engineering i shouldn't put that in air
quotes it's a legitimate thing um
but um
basically how can you have a saying
say i would say like
lucy like how can you have a same set of
sequel scripts that
very cleanly like
orchestrate like
all your cleaning in the warehouse
you know like the whole thing of like i
create a table and then another table
depends on it and another table depends
on it
that's the like high level part is this
kind of dependency graph
but also they've really refined i think
the practice of
warehousing and like the the classic
moves you'll need to do a lot of those
have made it into dbt so it's easy just
to stamp down
kind of like
a thing like they have snapshots and
that's i need to stop air quoting things
but um
so that's like a move you can do now
with dbt
and it's super handy
cool thank you
i know just before people were jumping
on we were talking a little bit about mo
about code for philly too and
you told me a pretty awesome story about
some of the work that
you did with that organization um
would you be able to share that example
with us
so code for philly
um
it's weird because
uh we spend a lot of time like talking
to non-profits and learning about their
problems um
uh
i would say the biggest problem we have
is just connecting volunteers with
something that's impactful like a lot of
volunteers that used to come in
would just have kind of random ideas
they wanted to build but they wouldn't
be as focused on kind of like
what a lot of non-profits at philly
we're hitting
um
but but from time to time we've been
able to really connect on
great partnerships so
so one was right at the beginning of the
pandemic last
i don't know how many years uh at the
beginning of the pandemic it's like
march 2020
you know where we're like um deep in our
apartments um and we connected with penn
medicine
to
create a covid monitoring dashboard so
actually a dashboard for capacity
planning for hospitals
and and that was like such a stressful
but
uh it helped helpful projects um to like
connect with this team like data science
team that just wanted to put up a
dashboard
and help them make it open source
and then wrangle like all the people who
came in so
lenode came in and they provided
resources
um we started getting like 300
people a week coming into our slack
which was like
10 percent
like we have 5 000 people so our slack
started growing and we had to like
moderate
um
so it's a lot of just how do you connect
people with these things and help them
grow and
really it's like a lot of slack channel
wrangling and kind of like doc
writing but um that so that that to me
was like a nice cook freely project we
were able to just connect two groups of
people and then work on all the
communication and kind of like
untangling
uh that comes along with it
cool
thank you
um i saw libby you put a question into
the chat if you want to jump in
sure yeah i was wondering if you if
you've ever had to defend your
psychology background as being data
related this is this happens to be a
conversation that i was just having this
past week with a lot of my friends in
the data space that are from psych
sociology
demography like applied to biography
um that have had to kind of defend their
education as being quantitative i'm just
wondering if you ever
hit that
yeah that's it's
such a great question i feel like um
yeah like my whole educational
background is tuned towards
i would say like
psychology is the most important thing i
think i bring but uh
everything else is just like getting in
the door to
defend against that like like to bring
in that reality so i uh doubled major in
undergrad in psychology and statistics
and then i did a pretty computational
phd
um in uh psychometrics so that's sort of
the methodological side of psychology
um
but i i say this because actually
like that yeah a lot of engineers are
happy with that they're like man that's
great
but
it's hard to explain actually i think
the most important parts i got were the
psychology parts like
research and design
and actually like
being able to decompose weird hard
problems and concepts um
so yeah i i think it's a never-ending
battle
um
to
to like elevate what psychologists do
like i i think every discussion about
metrics is kind of a psychological
discussion um
but
uh yeah i i don't think i've gotten a
lot of traction by saying like i'm a
psychologist i'm ready to help with your
metrics problem it's more than like
somehow going in the back door
um if that makes sense
yeah one of my um
advisors in in uh grad school always
said like
uh
empaths or empathetic people always make
the best data sciences because you can
kind of put different hats on to
put yourself in different shoes and
being able to analyze all of that data
so i think like having psychology or
having a different background
not only like
does it bring new questions but you can
also relate it in different concepts
right so it's super cool
yeah yeah i think totally in
it
i mean i think the psychologist side
also
hits a lot of really good product
management type skills um
that i think psychologists are very good
at like wrangling the high level
problems and
like cohering
a whole like
set of problems into kind of like a plan
or coherent whole so i i do think like
uh i i've like there's a couple of data
scientists like junior data scientists
i've been mentoring and to me they have
like
really great psychology skills they're
really good at
breaking down the problems and so
i don't i'm really hopeful for
psychologists as people who can
make not necessarily great data science
managers but like
do that weird data science work of like
lay the problems out and help things
like move along beyond like
coding things up
i also think you guys get a lot more
experimental design than people realize
and it's
so so important it's something that a
lot of other people in other disciplines
don't get and so it's something you guys
can bring to the team i know from my my
psych teammates that's something big
they bring to the team it's really
really wonderful it's interesting that
people
um
come up against that kind of barrier
sometimes because there should be more
visibility into it you guys are so
important
i really love this topic too of
like the skills that we have that make
us very successful in what we do that
might not necessarily be the skill that
people think on paper
would make you successful in it
you see andy you put a comment in the
chat too did you want to jump in
oh just i this is echoing really true
for um for my grad experience i have a
master's degree in system science and so
we
it's the basis of looking at things as
systems of interacting parts rather
and how you can uh look at the parts and
the holes of of things and um and that's
you know a lot of systems thinking in
systems theory and and um it actually
um that that program came out of a
psychology um
phd program at portland state university
and um so i just a lot of this
discussion is really ringing true for
for me and i did um an applied
statistics alongside of it and so
i got the experimental design and and
and some of that and that's really where
i m that was my entry to r and data
science um and so i but i entirely lean
on that for
like the access to work and projects
and stuff and the system stuff is just
like oh you can do systems mapping
awesome you know it's like well you know
the way that we're we have mental models
that you know that are very relevant in
what we're studying here and so being
able to
um you know talk about those and and use
those as well like i think it's really
valuable but it's funny how much i have
to explain it sometimes
yeah that makes a lot of sense
thanks andy i see uh sam you have your
hand raised too if you want to jump in
yeah i think this is a really
interesting topic and it's something
that i've been um
dealing maybe struggling with is not is
maybe too strong but dealing with is
sort of maybe not strong enough at work
recently where
some of these things that aren't like
hard data science
skills that are more like soft skills
are
i'm finding really undervalued
where i'm at especially in like the the
technical teams of things um so i work
on a team of data scientists and
software engineers
and i'm sort of
wondering like i really think that soft
skills are really valuable and that's
maybe my like private liberal arts
undergraduate degree sort of coming
through
um but you know how do you get more
buy-in from from people on like
basically getting them to
to basically believe that soft skills
are important and that it's important to
spend time on them as well as on like
the hardcore like data science software
engineering stuff
yeah that's a great question
i'm curious like what kind of
soft skill
so you're thinking or like what kind of
problems you're thinking even for like
um
where the soft skills would really come
to bear
yeah a lot of the stuff i'm thinking
about and that i've been struggling with
is
specifically when it comes to record
keeping
so things like taking minutes at
meetings
making agendas for meetings
commenting your code
documenting processes or workflows
things like that
yeah that's uh
that's a great question
because i i will say like the only from
my last
job the the person i meet with regularly
right now is like a junior data
scientist who
whose
like standout skill was amongst other
things like record keeping
so like that i i think that's huge
uh
i i wouldn't be surprised if like
uh
in my view like a lot of those things
almost
if you can like wrangle them into
existence like if you can
make it happen or just like they're a
void and and someone will feel it
eventually or
when it like
with once the note taking happens i
think that
people really tend to rally behind it so
uh but i i'd be curious to
yeah i i'm really curious about
situations where
do you mean like the team maybe like you
have a team of data scientists and it's
hard to like get people
note-taking or
yeah so i'm i'm by no means like a
leader of a team of data scientists i am
definitely like
one of the people being led um and we
sort of have like a hierarchy where
there's like a manager and then there's
a data science manager and a software
engineering manager and then there's a
few people floating around underneath
and i'm sort of floating around in the
data science area
and i've been i've only been at this
company for about a year and a half
right now um
and i'm just finding myself really
like i can't figure out like what
processes are or you know what people
are
trying to do or you know
basically how to how to communicate like
other stuff people are working what
they're working on and sort of where
they need help and if somebody needs to
switch to a project which happens quite
a bit um getting context on that project
is really difficult um things like that
yeah
yeah yeah that's a
thanks that's that's really helpful to
hear i think like if
yeah teams and they're like a few
different it sounds like pieces involved
like some engineers
data science their managers um but maybe
a lot of cross-cutting
concerns i i think one of the most
impactful things i saw was there is uh
this really great
uh
consultant i worked with last year named
kane bocce galoopi and they
they kind of blew my mind they they
introduced 15 minutes daily stand-ups
and i
prior to that hated stand-ups um
but but the one thing they introduced
that really
uh amazed me was they said like
and
it's just stand up it's like 15 minutes
it has to end in 15 minutes and
you can't have like a product manager
trying to work a backlog in the meantime
and then i realized that every stand-up
i didn't like was did have a manager
trying to like update the status of
different things
um but to me it's like game changing to
just get people in a room for 15 minutes
just to say what they did like that's
the goal
everybody says what they're working on
and that
that for me has been really helpful for
like
figuring out you have like this big stew
of people
sometimes hitting different things
um
that
if you hear what people are working on
oftentimes it's enough to figure out
like oh who do i have to connect with
afterwards
or like
who should i like chat with um
i i don't know if that's useful but that
really kind of like changed my
work life um
because it's hard to get people to take
notes or even to know where the notes
will live or that they'll be relevant
um it seems like just getting people in
a room
uh
and not making that an adverse
experience like just making it a very
simple experience sometimes really like
cuts down this insane like
issue of like needing notes but notes go
out of date or often aren't um
should write you know like the right
grain for us often
yeah
that's a great question sam i see
there's a lot of people that have some
thoughts in the chat too and caitlyn i
was wondering if you want wondering if
you want to jump in too
sure i hope you guys can hear me okay
because my wifi is not very good but yes
um
okay cool so i yeah i do all that too so
i work on a team of like four-ish um
data scientists as well who are always
kind of transferring um code with each
other and
i think
even though we're kind of working on the
same thing there's so many different
ways to tackle the same problem and like
there's so many
like
yeah it's a it's a really tough
situation but i think even just like
trying to interp
for other people's code or what they're
doing what i found most helpful is
honestly just like michael said jumping
on a call with someone and almost like
over communicating um just to because
it's a win-win for everyone like you'll
understand the code and then
be able to do like your job better so i
think it's never a bad thing to over
communicate or just literally ask as
many questions as possible
we're learning that here too
more communication is better
i see andy you had some other thoughts
on it too if you want to jump in
well just the um that sometimes changing
the label of what you're doing rather
than um you know
saying that the soft skill is your
coordination is your coordination
efforts um
using like project management language
or something like that just gives people
a little more access to like seeing the
value in what you're doing
um
and that's
i guess it was just a comment that it
sounds a lot like
um the the work is in you know in the
spirit of like continuity of operations
and so
if um if
sometimes it's just helping folks see
where the value is compared to what it
is that they value i don't know
yeah that's a great point too
i don't want to jump from this topic too
quickly if there are other thoughts too
i was curious michael what it's been
like for you coming coming from a team
from leading a data science team
back into
um
like more of an individual contributor
role yeah that's a great question uh
well
i think our studio is so in my
mind
the tidiverse team is so
great i almost like it and i gave a talk
last year our studio conf on porting
sorry i have a
window over here with a fat bird outside
so it's like cat tv
um
but um
yeah uh
uh actually i i would say like um
it's been really nice and i think that
um
the challenge managing was like um
i was learning a ton basically about
like
data engine i i had like great people
at all parts of the stack and so i was
learning a lot about like data
engineering and
data science and analytics um
but not a lot of time to kind of develop
or
really take a lot of those ideas and put
them together in tools um
so it's been really nice to be
on the tidyverse team and
um
now just like seeing people take a lot
of insights and build tools out of them
um
has been really nice um
but uh
yeah so i would say the thing i miss for
managing is like
really smart people telling me how wrong
i am about
a lot of things um
what what i really like about the
tidyverse team is now there are these
incredible people like trying to just
take
these like insights and kind of like
bottle them into
tools so that everyone can kind of like
use them easily
i i definitely won't miss all the
meetings though managing was a lot more
uh
meetings yeah
thanks michael and um i get to ask you
all these questions if people don't have
other ones so
reminder you can always just raise your
hand jump in put in the zoom
chat or you can use slido 2 to ask
anonymously um
but when you just said that it was
making me think um when you said like a
lot of people telling you
how wrong something is they're giving
feedback like when you were a manager
how did you handle
those conversations and
and
creating an environment where people
felt comfortable to do that
yeah i think um
i think one really helpful
framing was like
giving people
an escape hatch for criticizing my work
which was like
hey
uh
so this is what exists now
and like in a kind of
like i had this weird trade-off where
i was like one person
but uh like my goal was to
help the organization see how useful
data science could be so we could bring
you in
to like
make it extra great
and i think that
the framing of like so what i did was
actually pretty bad and
it was just to like get the vision out
that we needed you
um and now you're here so uh i think
that's helpful because people could be
like hey
i'm really glad that you like did this
work
and like pushed out an insight
it like all needs to be fixed now like
um
especially like the data engineering
i do more like data science analytics i
think um
so they're able to be like i'm glad that
this worked and like something came out
um and now that i'm here like we need to
just rewrite it to be like
robust where robust is a code word for
like
what you did was not
super great and will probably break
in like unforeseen ways
but i i found that helpful just to like
actually for both of us to have that
like
hey i i yeah i did this it's probably
bad
uh i was really focused on pushing
things out and and i'm glad you're here
to like
make it right
that's awesome thank you uh olivia so
you just raised your hand
yeah i was gonna ask you michael you
brought up something that i've been
talking with people about this week as
well which is the structure of data
science teams and how
um
some teams are like just data scientists
and they've got an i.t team that will
support them and implement models and do
the engineering side of things and there
are some teams out there that have data
scientists who are also data engineers
and then there are teams where there are
both data engineers and data scientists
working together in tandem on things to
make sure that stuff doesn't get stuck
in like a development pipeline and have
to be refactored before deployment um
what are your thoughts on structuring
data science teams including engineering
or not
yeah that's
it's like the
it's such a tricky
problem i think and there are a lot of
different
pitches on structures i listen to um
i know jaclyn nolan's talked a bit about
it on a data science hangout and she
said like
that she started believing that there
were virtues to different ones but ended
up sort of
sold on the decentralized model where
data scientists are embedded in teams
um
i i think i agree that
the data scientists and analysts should
be sitting with the teams that they're
pushing out reports for um
it just
uh i mean otherwise i would be trying to
send people into those teams to figure
out what they want and their priorities
um
i think a good data scientist works with
like a pm or whoever's leading the team
to
like both like push up metrics but also
kind of like help
change the road map
um
that i think it leaves the tricky
question of like where should data
engineers be um and how should they
interact with the teams
um
it does it seems okay that
today like data engineers i think are
doing more like tooling empowerment so
i think they're a good team to have like
yeah it's okay to have them a bit more
centralized
and like connecting to the
data scientists to like enforce best
practices or enable like new
pieces for them i i think that's a nice
model like data
analysts data scientists live in the
teams
and data engineers are kind of like
spokes of a wheel where then the data
scientists connect with them
and they work closely to like enforce
best practice and enable like new
important
things
i'd be curious what people use though
sorry now i have a cat just right here
so
[Laughter]
tattoo i i see you had your hand raised
was it on this topic
yeah i think it's it's related to a lot
of things right um i think you know
largely what you're saying michael is
kind of use your use your tools at your
disposal right and i think that you know
people like rachel and myself who aren't
necessary in in a standard data
scientific sort of role but in a world
where we kind of interface with a lot of
folks in different functions in the
company
and i think it's really important that
we've talked about this before but it's
important to find your translators right
and it's important to kind of um use the
power of feedback i know rachel's a huge
proponent of taking feedback and
actually making it into something
um actionable but like really like you
know reach out to those peoples those
people right like you know
michael and i uh recently worked on
something together or we're trying to
get some feedback um based on something
that he's working on and i feel like um
i i think michael's pretty amazing at
actually putting things in into action
as well but um you know i i think that
you have a lot of folks out there that
are willing to to help you do what you
need to and you don't need to be so kind
of you know focused just on what you're
doing i i think you'll find that if
you're able to kind of get somebody from
a different perspective that can also
kind of level with you um it's really
a lot a lot easier to like make
something happen so i just kind of
wanted to throw that up there
definitely thanks tatsu see george you
have
your hand raised to share some thoughts
too
yeah i thought that was quite um cool
talking about where the data science
system where the data engineers go
because so i deal with
just insurance companies but i go from
insurance company to insurance company
and they're non-life companies and i'm
dealing with the actuaries mostly
and pretty much the model that i'm
trying to get more insurance companies
to take in it's because they've come
from this really traditional
landscape where you've got lots of
actuaries working on lots of excel
spreadsheets and it's getting to it's
been at the limit of that for years but
it's at the limit of that and there's a
real lack of knowledge share and tool
sharing and that's where the data
science element comes in
but for me within the organization you
need to have this team
that's
i guess it's kind of like a mini spoke
if you will because they're central to
the actuarial team which is a spoke of
an insurance company but within that
team i think
for this speed of integration especially
so where it is now in the life cycle i
think you need a data engineer you need
a couple of data scientists they need to
be kind of a jackable trades around
sort of start to finish but the most
important thing is they need to be
remote from the it team and they need to
be with the actuarial team i think
if it's too far removed and they're back
with the it team and stuff you end up
with the old problems and they don't get
the business concept and then you have a
migration or something and it doesn't
work and it goes back to square one and
but this time everyone's really
livid about um
transformation and bringing in data
science because they did it once already
it didn't work and it cost x million
dollars and they don't want to go again
um so i think yeah so i for me within my
teams it's all about getting
enough skills so they can get stuff done
especially proof of concepts and then if
you need to go back and sort of take
stuff back at a step um then that's
where you where you might look at that
centralized model again but yeah that
that's that's my thoughts on it and and
my experience
i think i think that's like spot on that
uh
the set the more central it is
it's like um kind of a diverge converge
thing that a central team helps like
practice converge to
like uh what they see as like best
practice but
in your case if you're describing like
pushing out something new or
you know like getting something out that
requires data engineering
that it seems important that's like kind
of diverging and going into exploring a
new area or a new lane of work
just just setting a data engineer there
to allow it to actually
do whatever it needs versus like do what
a big body thinks is
yeah
yeah yeah but if you want to bring it
back and and
you're right converge to the company
wide and make sure that everything's
sort of on on the same platform then
it's important to bring it back again
yeah but that i think it's spot on just
making sure that that that converging
back kind of doesn't stifle
creativity or prevent a team from doing
the right thing kind of even if it
breaks from
what's happening now
yeah
manny i saw you unmuted do you have
anything to add to that uh
i do yeah i do and i don't i guess i
guess i'm on
i'm on the it team right now
and i guess there there are thoughts of
like okay well
you know are we speaking the same
language because i feel like being in
data science and it's such a new field
so i'm in data science for real estate
it's kind of a new field and it's new
for the company too
so it's almost like
i can fit in anywhere but nowhere at the
same time it's kind of how i feel
so i guess there's like a sort of
identity of where where does data
science fall it's kind of like we know
we need it um and so it doesn't fall
under i.t or does it fall
under a corporate operations or
and and it's interesting because like
the i.t team is is fantastic and
they're
um
you know they're very structured and
they they're kind of like they've been
in the business forever
and data science
is so fluid and so creative and so kind
of like non-structured at the moment
that
you know you kind of have to look at
where where it actually does bono i
don't know that i have the answer for
that
but i can agree with george and michael
and
everybody else that kind of chimed in so
a comment i guess
i think we covered everybody who wanted
to chime in on on this topic too but a
great discussion point um and i see
caitlyn you had
another question in the chat would you
want to jump in
sure so yeah michael i was just
wondering if you've ever
used data science within the psychology
domain
yeah i so i worked on a
skill assessment tool that um like an
adaptive
assessment um which was sort of right in
my wheelhouse
in psychology um
and so there we had a small team of like
me an engineer and some content creators
um
and we uh we're just working on
basically a new product
um but but it was different in that um
the company hadn't focused on like
psychology things um
and so the whole idea of like a test
and um
the the psychology classics like test
reliability validity were new
to the company and so
uh
that was an interesting one where we
both had to prepare the data coming in
to um be quick to analyze
but also sort of like lay out the
concepts um
behind it um
and kind of roll out like an adaptive
testing
thing
um
i i think the most interesting thing
there that happened is i produced a lot
of like long-form
articles about it at the company so
about like how does this thing work
um
you know showing like it in practice in
our data
um so there's this thing called the um
so for one like the cold start problem
that means um
if you start rolling out a test
you don't have any data on it but if
it's an adaptive test you kind of need
data
to do the right thing and so it's an
adaptive test it gets better over time
you know as you learn how hard the
questions are
um and things like that um
so there i i had to like write articles
to the company about like what can we do
in this case um with a little bit of
like
psychological theory um
i i will say i think the most
interesting thing i
took out of it though was
um it was the opposite from
psychological research where i usually
went
like more complex i would like research
like usually dive deep into something um
a lot of
a lot of this case was about saying like
we could go deep but we like shouldn't
like um
like you might think that we should go
really hard into like reliability and do
the exact right
like most rigorous measurement
um but we like shouldn't do that uh
because we're building like a test
product and so actually
the scientific rigor is only like
a piece of this kind of like
emerging story it would be really bad if
we had a very rigorous we spent a lot of
time on rigor and nobody was taking the
assessment so it's kind of like
balancing that out saying like i'm an
expert at this thing
what you're doing is fine we can like
shortcut in
uh this thing yeah i i think that goes
back to the question people asked to
about soft skills in psychology like
i feel a lot of that was like saying
like hey we could do the math and we
could roll out something very mathy but
actually
like soft skills um we should just focus
on users and just patch in like
the quickest
most reasonable thing
yeah that's really cool thanks
thank you travis i see you just put a
question to the chat if you want to jump
in
sure um that's a question i like to ask
other data science leaders what you look
for in data science resumes cover
letters which screening process is like
seems like every time
we post something these days at our work
we get tons and tons of resumes and the
screening process is hard um because
there are lots of really really good
candidates out there um
you have like a quick method a
you know like right to triage things
i don't know what are the flags you look
for typically
that's a good question
uh
i feel like
uh i'm i'm always really interested in
like can this person create a slide show
like um it's like hugo bound
anderson in his article like what data
scientists do according to like 35 data
scientists it um
said something like
yeah like maybe the most important skill
is like making a slideshow um
i i think that's important it's like
can they communicate do we think they
could like sit with the team and
actually like
um
understand its goals and work with the
the pm
uh but then
uh
as to how you screened for that i have
no idea actually i i'm really stumped
that that's like what i'd love to
have insight into i think it's really
hard to
get at
the other thing is that
um
i i'm a strong believer that
in fast live
real-time data analysis that
that not enough do we like
have a data scientist just try to pull
our data like companies data scientists
and companies really vary in their
ability to just
answer questions from data live
i i think that's a really important
skill for being able to drive the ship
and
gain the trust of like a pm
um
so
and and i think like a good example of
this is um dave robinson
um uses is an r user uses the tidy verse
and he feels comfortable enough to just
live analyze data for an hour a week on
youtube
um
i think that's so important that a
person can do that fast it's like it's
like a communication skill basically
like
do you have enough data science fluency
to communicate
with data
like a conversation with a person
um
and that that's kind of why i started
so i i maintain a port of d plier to
python called suba
um
and that's a lot of why i started
porting it is because i was working with
really good
r users who could analyze data
in real time
and i just couldn't do it in python um
so
uh
i i think that's critical basically um
how you measure it i don't know i think
um
there are a lot of ways you could do it
with um like realistic
scenarios and tests um
i i don't think people should be
subjected to that kind of like pressure
in an interview necessarily like
um
like you
you know you have like laser eyes on
them and want them to analyze data that
would probably like be a really
stressful thing for a lot of people
um
but but i think that skill somehow
has to be like sussed out and
enter the picture you can have a lot of
i should say you could have a lot of
good data scientists who can't
do this
and that's okay too but i think there's
all orgs need like these people
basically
yeah that's great answers thanks
i see there's a lot of of great thoughts
in the chat and i had a similar question
to yours tatsu because they know
if something looks really nice like the
same way if
a shiny app or data visualization looks
really nice you might think it's better
than something else
and tatsu you asked a question about
appearance if you want to jump in
i'm i'm thinking like this is the case
where like reading the book by its cover
actually does matter right like in this
specific case where you're a data
scientist you have to be able to like
take that up make it and make it appear
in a way that's digestible to people
right so i i would almost think that
that it's true but i don't know what you
think michael
yeah i think like a designer um
your resume is kind of a portfolio in a
way um
because you're a data scientist won't
just be in a cave they'll be
actually interfacing with people so how
they present
this like initial how they give you this
initial
glimpse into the who they are uh in a
lot of ways is
a very data sciency
interaction i yeah i think you're
on to something
but i also realize people don't have a
ton of time to make resumes so
uh
i can see the value of like
presenting them with a problem right
that lets them kind of like bring that
to bear
um
i like i like yeah i was gonna say i
like travis's comment of like you could
spot if somebody's made the wrestling
hair without remark i think that's a
good screener
for sure
um i see alice you had a comment in the
chat do you want to jump in
if i can unmute yeah hey um hi no i
think that i just wanted to like
circle back on the idea of like
screening resumes is super challenging
because you get basically
you have no idea why somebody applied
based on them sending you like a
document they send to like 100 other
companies
so i i really like the idea of having
people answer like one or two screening
questions which actually gets out like
the kind of key criteria that you're
looking for a job or forces somebody to
respond to like specifically what you're
looking for and you get that kind of
customized like okay
what i'm looking for is how curious is
somebody really about this position how
engaged are they are they really
interested in working in this industry
or did they get like a linkedin
saying like hey you should apply to this
job because i've talked to candidates
like i get on the phone with them and
i'm like hey why did you apply to this
job and they were like oh it came up on
my linkedin
and i was like oh my god
no
no that's not what i need um so i don't
know if there are better platforms or
ways to get people to like
yeah i love cover letters too if
somebody sends a cover letter it's like
an automatic conversation with me
um
so yeah if there are ways and platforms
and things to get like
uh you know some sort of gauge on like
more than just a resume that's priceless
yeah i think that's fair
it's a tough one
um
i
yeah i will say two like one one thing
that worries me about
using the resume is um
so like one one weird fact about me is i
uh i did grad school at princeton
but i i'm a real barbarian i actually
had no idea like what princeton was
before i went my my advisor basically
just pitched me there
and the only reason i bring this up is
like um
i didn't know that
grad students went to school for free at
princeton and so
when i like first i almost didn't apply
there because i legitimately believed
they would charge me
an incredible amount of money and two
when i was there i was so freaked out
because i
no one told me that it was free and so
um
i was like sitting through the like
interviews and like the or like the um
visit like
with this freaky problem just hanging
over me um
and so i i think with resumes and just
jobs there's there's that whole thing
it's like the less spooky we can be
like
actually like at the point that a person
submits a resume we haven't even
probably cued them to what we want so
like
that's why one hesitation of using the
resume itself um beyond maybe like
a broad kind of entry point um
is that
as a company it's probably our
responsibility to really
very clearly tell people what
we're like evaluating them on
and just helping them appreciate
actually what
is being used in the process so that
i do think the resume is really is a
reflection of kind of data science
skill to a degree but um
my one hesitation is that like once we
actually bring people into the interview
that we have the chance to like tee them
up on our expectations and so
um i i think everything prior to that i
would kind of
uh just just in terms like equity and
where people come in from uh
be careful to really like
be super critical of
great point michael
i see
libby you had a great idea um
from your cover letter and a lot of
people are commenting on it so i'd love
for you to share that if that's okay
yeah sure i can talk about that so
um last year and i'm to preface a
statement like i'm um a career switcher
so like i'm in my mid to late 30s and i
was having to find an internship last
year and finding an internship in your
30s is weird and it's hard it's like
people see your resume that's full of
lots of experience and think like why is
this person applying for a resume or
playing for an internship so i attended
a talk
that was led by
polly mitchell guthrie
at canaxis which is a canadian company
supply chain analytics software company
and
i noticed that she happened to be hiring
an intern
in strategy she's the vp of thought
leadership and industry outreach i was
like how cool is that that's amazing my
undergrad is very supply chain oriented
um
so i reached out to her asked her a
little bit about the position let her
know i was interested
and then um applied and in my cover
letter i added
kind of in the place of one of my
paragraphs you know you have a few small
paragraphs and a cover letter
and at the end of my my paragraphs i was
like i feel really passionate about xyz
and if you have the time to watch this
very quick two-minute youtube video i
think it'll it'll explain why i'm
passionate about it and had just a
little link to my video um and i i got
the job and that was definitely what
sealed the deal like everybody told me i
can't believe you made a video for your
cover letter that's amazing we've never
seen that before i had some like quick
animations in there that i did on my
ipad it was nothing fancy and i actually
recorded the video the day after i got
my kobe vaccine so i was really sick um
so it doesn't have to be perfect it just
has to be
real and authentic and you know you and
connected to like i talked directly to
her i was like hi polly how's it going
you know in my video
i highly recommend that for anybody who
wants
you know them to get across but it
wouldn't have worked if i hadn't had her
email if i hadn't attended her talk if i
hadn't reached out to her and been an
actual person
i love that libby
thanks for sharing that with us
yeah that's super cool
this is also so nice it's like
you can just open it on your phone and
see
yeah i don't think i'd recommend more
than a minute or two minutes right
show people you value their time
yeah
i'm scrolling through all of the uh
the cheers to you libby and to find the
other questions let's see was there
anything i missed earlier
oh i see jackie you just asked a
question do you want to jump in
or i can read the question too and if
you want to add more
contacts feel free to jump in
but it was what do you think of having
an online portfolio or shiny app
if you can do it i mean the more
i think the more kind of like stuff
people can see and interact with the
the better if the code's on github it's
super handy to have um i don't know if
people will read through it in detail
but even its existence is i think really
a
big
indicator that
i mean you've got like a portfolio of
work that
you were able to put up um
which is probably what you'll be doing a
lot as a data scientist is like pushing
up projects and stuff so
definitely i know javier had talked
about
doing that before
i don't know javier's on
but um
let's see
oh there you are i just got to say javi
is definitely on um yeah i
this actually
you know i don't think i got the current
job i'm in right now because of this but
um
[Music]
speaking to a team of people that had
been surrounded by data their whole
careers who weren't really that familiar
with
you know our as the programming language
or some of the capabilities of like
shiny i think
you know i built
a pretty lightweight shiny app um using
the bslib framework
and thematic and a few other popular
packages and it kind of blew their mind
um
and i think that's just
you know the nature of them
being surrounded by like
excel dashboards or um
[Music]
you know like kind of
tableau can make amazing things but the
tableau dashboards i usually see in
production
are
just to kind of summarize data quickly
like they serve a very useful function
but
they're not really
aesthetically pleasing in my opinion
um so
sharing kind of a real lightweight
you know shiny app um went a long way
they told me afterwards they were like
that app went all over the company we're
so happy that you made that
so
i themed it as if it was their product
so i took like their logo and their
color scheme and i made the whole
shiny app look as if it was you know
a bloom reach
like data product
that's amazing i was looking for the
link that we had shared on a past
hangout when you shared that but i'm not
good at multitasking here so
um george i see you had your hand raised
too
yeah i was just gonna say i think i
think that last point that you made
there javier on um
uh
uh putting it into their brand and their
style and and it being on topic is the
the most important thing i think from my
experience um it's really difficult to
choose like just a general thing that
shows you can do data science like um
most data sciences scientists i'd say
can can see
the
um
sort of the broader aspect of what you
can do with data and stuff but take it
outside anyone there and even though
you've done something really impressive
with numbers producing really good
results if it's not in their domain
people are really bad i think at seeing
the transferable skills and that's
that's my biggest experience so in terms
of having demos i think they're really
good and i wanted to get some up on my
website portfolio and that sort of thing
um and i always sort of struggle to
choose the right one and actually just
gotta make a decision and get something
up but it's that sort of thing as well i
think it's like if you're going through
like your dream job you kind of almost
have to really fire it up and make it
really specialized to that because in my
experience if you go into a
insurance company or a banking company
or whatever with
your favorite sport and you've taken all
the data and you've brought it together
and you've put out this really kick-ass
graphic
and then they just all look at it and go
yeah but we do banking you're like
yeah but it's just numbers it's all just
numbers like can you not see it i find
it so frustrating that people can't just
see that you can just do all this with
numbers and it's transferable to every
business and every company and every
hobby in the world
yeah that's my thing
that's an awesome point george
um i know an hour is going by extremely
quickly uh can i see brittany you asked
a great question
in the chat a little bit earlier would
you want to jump in
sure i can jump in um so i think i've
heard this question a lot around like
having some sort of portfolio and i'm
just because i keep hearing it more and
more often i think i just love to ask
the room do you
think it's becoming one of those things
that's more and more important
that maybe people should think about
prioritize prioritizing time to create
if they're looking in the job market and
if they are
what kinds of things do you think that
we should be including that portfolio is
it just
very simple like data analysis is it
um like maybe actually doing more of a
shiny app is it more of like an actual
model and like full out model building
process like if someone wants to invest
the time what do you think they should
do to do that wisely
any thoughts michael or larry i see your
have your have your hand right cool yes
i'm on all right uh sorry i'm very
passionate about this one uh
with the projects i've noticed that i'm
not more i'm more on the consulting side
but with the projects
if i hire somebody to help me on a
project i'm looking at
how they go through the process so
i ask them if they have a project that
they did to gather data i asked them if
they have a project that they did to
clean the data then i ask them uh the
analyze the visualization maybe a side
deck and if they can walk through that
whole process then i can see they can do
the whole process from beginning to end
gathering data they can go find data
sets use them apply them
combine them and then get inside out of
them that's that's the projects i look
for
but i'm more on the greenland side so
i don't know if that helps but those are
what i'm looking at
thanks larry i like
i like tatsu's comment about having your
name.shinyapps.io
as a signal
so true a lot of times though if i'm not
hiring for a shiny developer that might
not be relevant something that does help
a lot though is if they have a site
maybe through netlify with github
something like that
things like the new postcards package
helps just make that possibly just a one
pager just shows that they care about
kind of making
our markdown and other html documents
things like that talk to each other it's
really helpful to know
yeah i think
it's also such a great way to get
feedback like um
from people
like if
uh
yeah i i think portfolio is a nice one
it's like a victory lap you get to show
off like all your hard work um
so that's i i think that's super nice i
think two is like um
applying for jobs
uh
i think applying for jobs it's so nice
to find like other people who like are
also looking for data science jobs or
working as data scientists and then a
portfolio
even i i would see the silver like the
nice thing is even versus like um
sending it to a company you're applying
to being able to connect with people and
like show your work to them um and like
you know like talk about it and
work on stuff i think that's
also a really exciting piece
um yeah i think the portfolio is
huge some brittany was part of the
question about like knowing what
the project should be that you work on
for them too or
yeah i think larry gave some insight um
and a couple others did too but just
it sounds like it's a little more of
what we might consider the basics and
not so like
super fancy crazy modeling types of
things and okay
yeah i would i would start like just by
even boxing your time and deciding like
how long you want to spend on it and
then work backwards
um because the the biggest risk is that
the projects never happen like and i
know this is true for me like i just
want to end up creating the perfect
project but if i
block my time to like one day
you know that then at least you can just
get something out and then
like it i think it also really sharpens
thinking around like how much is good
enough
i know um tori just dropped but she had
a great comment in the chat too and
i think this is an awesome like other
side effect of it but it's like if you
are creating that shiny app or like
libby did with the youtube
video and they're sharing it around the
company
that's also
amazing for building relationships
across the company even before you start
and then recognizing who you are
it's really cool
um i see javier you have a question i
know we're a minute over and just want
to make sure michael you have
a few other minutes
yeah is that is it should i um oh no i i
just uh see javier put it in if you want
to read it
sure yeah yeah
yeah the question's just like how are
you staffed how does our studio staff
you um onto
you know new projects like are you
working on multiple problems at the same
time or is it more like
you know you're personally very curious
about some aspect of the tidy verse that
you want to kind of dive deeper and try
to improve or like how does that kind of
staffing model work at our studio
yeah that's
so i i'm probably not the best person as
i've been here for like a couple a few
months but i think
i mean the tidy verse team is just
so great and
um self like motivated i mean i think
everyone on the team is sort of like a
fanatic in a way like they have a
problem that they really want to solve
they
they're very much like they remind me a
lot of researchers and so
really i think a lot of it
seems to fall out pretty naturally that
it's pretty weird for people to have
like
this kind of focus like um
thomas on ggplot2 like
uh you're just not gonna see that level
of dedication i think um
a lot and so i think
that like the hard part is kind of done
i think with a lot of people on the team
it's it's like people with weird
obsessions um so i have to say like i
don't know why i've just been
dedicated to porting tools to python for
the past three years like um
like i use python a lot but wish i was
using the tidy verse
and so it's like with that
just knowing that i've been weirdly been
working on this for three years it like
falls out pretty naturally like figuring
out
what's what's a good thing to work on
and i'm so i'm working with julia sylgay
right now and to her credit she's like
incredibly
great and you know like flexible and
interested in finding the right
thing so i think it's it's a lot about
maybe people chasing their weird
very specific our python related um
obsessions if that makes sense it's a
great it's a great team it's very it
seems very autonomous and
um
i i would say kind of weird in its focus
that people have very specific
incredible focuses
thanks michael
thank you um michael before we go i want
to ask you um
about some of the things that you're
working on and or things we should be
keeping an eye on or checking out as
well yeah that's a great question i
should have brought this up early so
uh i'm working with julia silgae and um
uh isabelle zimmerman
on um model lops so this is like how can
we make it really easy to go from a
trained model
to something you're able to serve so
people can actually
right like interact with or a service
can use it
say like on a platform
um
and so that that's been really exciting
to see like
um
a lot of the tidy models is focused on
like making it easy to train models
you know and do all that and then that
last kind of like step
or mile which is like getting it off
your computer
onto somewhere else
and running as say like a web
application
so i've been really excited about that
and then
i would say just working on python tools
in general i've been really excited to
uh
almost like i i love the insights that
people inside universe have so to almost
like think about
what's like some of the like magic that
they've captured that we can bring
into python
uh
to make data science a delight and
the the one thing i'll say there's data
science tools in python are really
interesting because i think
in general the engineering tools in
python are incredible so like
um
a lot a lot of the pieces like people in
the titiverse had to build out like the
foundational pieces are there
um i think it's just the tidy verse like
api and the high level
flow
um would would bring so much so
um
yeah super excited to work on that type
of stuff
that's great thank you so much michael i
see tatsu was sharing a few links
in the chat for us to check out as well
but thank you all so much for joining
today and for all the great questions
too
hopefully see you all back next week as
well
um but michael a huge thank you to you
for for filling in here last minute as
well really appreciate you
sharing your experience with us too
yeah no we haven't got a chance to talk
at our studio too
um no thanks for the opportunity it's i
think it's super great having a bunch of
people
in a room just talking about the weird
corners of data science
it's awesome thank you so much michael
have a great rest of the day everybody
you